so listen I I've really enjoyed your
work the last few years but
hypothetically say someone has never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why a great question um I
would i' I'd love people to watch time
which is a show that's just come out on
BBC um because that's just so opposite
for me and I think it's a cool one and I
think it's an interesting watch as well
but also Chicken Run sure it's also very
good um I'm curious what surprised you
about uh working with working on Chicken
Run and voicing a character Molly in
maybe ways you didn't expect I mean I'd
voiced some animation before but this
was I've sort of done an animation for
several years called HDE but this was
with an entirely new team and i' got
used to that like way of working with
the Hilda team so like it was a it it
was a learning curve for me to like
adapt to new ways of doing things um and
I I'm I'm always blown away just by how
like the process of animation and like
the sound Engineers just like being in a
studio and watching them like fiddle
around with like the buttons and the
sliders and because I've been I was
remote recording most of it like when I
was in Canada or when like wherever I've
been so just the fact that it can be
done from literally anywhere is like
remarkable I think same thing with like
interviewing people who are in London
and someone else is in La well
exactly so I am curious do you see any
similarities between Molly and Ellie or
do you think they're Polar Opposites no
there are definitely similarities I
think uh they both have a similar like
feistiness I think um they're similar in
that Molly it can be she's this like
Curious intelligent little chicken which
obviously Ellie isn't a chicken but this
curious intelligent little chicken who
wants to explore the world and thinks
that she's like Brave and can do
anything but then you see moments of her
being actually incredibly terrified and
I think that's the same with um with
Ellie she comes across as this very like
headstrong uh adult most of the time but
then you see these moments of her just
being like a terrified little child so I
think they have similarities in that
regard do you enjoy recording efforts or
do you dread them
I quite like efforts you know I think
that they're so bizarre um and so unlike
anything that you do in like live action
you when do you ever like make yourself
make like an oof sound you know it's so
weird uh yeah I quite like efforts I see
a sheet of efforts I'm like yeah this is
going to be fun also you just like
rattle through them there's so like set
sometimes like trying to get a very
particular o is pretty funny yeah I've
spoken to a lot of people and they tell
me that the efforts are always always at
the end of the day because you just
shred your voice y exactly especially if
there's screams exactly so I I read that
you're vegan um I'm assuming you're
still vegan and I'm curious if you had
any sort of personal connection uh to
this um you know being part of chicken
run because of that or not at all I mean
I actually didn't think about it when I
signed on to do chicken when I got the
audition I didn't like pick up on that
similarity uh in terms of like me being
vegan and not eating I've never like
I've always I've never had meat I grew
up in a I grew up pescatarian and I went
veggie then I went vegan um so I didn't
really make that connection but I think
that's because I've just it's always
been a part of my life not eating meat
that I wasn't like oh this is cool um
but now I think about it yeah like I
absolutely am behind the idea that we
can watch this fun animated movie about
chickens and then by the end of it be
like hm maybe I don't want to eat a
chicken nugget I think that's cool
obviously I a huge fan of last us um
like the rest of the world I'm just
curious uh do you know when you're
actually starting to film season two
next
year do you actually know or you don't
know no I do actually know um well I
mean yeah I like temporarily know things
are changing all the time I think with
the strikes everything's just obviously
now they're finished that's amazing and
we can actually get going and we can
talk about it um but I think it's
delayed a couple of things and
availability and stuff so we'll just
we'll see but it will happen at some
point next year which is exciting I'm
I'm sure the studio is like please start
filming as soon as you can um my last
thing for you about last of us uh is
what are you actually I'm sure you've
played the game I know you know the
story what are you most excited for in
season two to film is there like a
sequence or a scene or something that
you're already thinking about yeah lots
of things um I'm excited for the really
intense stuff uh cuz I did AIT a bit of
that in season one obviously but like to
do that and actually more physical
scenes cuz Ellie is obviously like more
physically fit in season 2 and like so
I'm looking forward to I
love stuff and like waking up with
bruises the next day
it's kind of bad and like finding myself
with a black eye just because it feels
like so good to have done so I'm looking
forward to doing that stuff and also the
Dina story line I think that's just
going to be because OB had the one in
season one with Ellie and Riley but to
have it sort of as a storyline
throughout the whole of like the second
game um in terms of Ellie and Dina is is
yeah really exciting that note I need to
stop I'm just going to say big fan
really uh congrats on everything that's
happening for you have a fantastic day
thank you so much you
too